[Music]
we always try to stay on well talk about
new technologies if they're out there
technologies that help enhance the way
viewers experience our program now one
area we've been focusing on is virtual
reality pretty cool stuff which is why
I'm happy to announce a new partnership
with virtual reality software developer
visual sauce
that's right tonight we're test
launching a new version of our own
virtual reality experience this is
amazing we've selected one lucky
audience member to experience it for the
very first time and I have his name here
is there a Keith Biederman here yes
hello oh hey okay should I should have
spotted you uh and you're ready Keith
just press the left side there's a
button on the left side of your head set
to activate cone and VR wow that's
really loud okay alright alright tell us
what do you see oh it looks exactly like
this show but it's like I'm totally
inside of it yeah amazing right
best part is everything is interactive
Keith okay for example you can virtually
walk up to the band right now virtually
grab an instrument and even play it try
it out Keith okay hey man nice hat
mind if I borrow your trombone it's a
really amazing technology it's
absolutely fantastic Keith what are you
doing running my hands through your hair
bro
feels like an old cat okay well don't
just stop that it's a little distracting
oh I'm sorry here let me fix your hair
real quick no no it's not you're not
really fixing its virtual reality okay
and folks this technology is so
incredible what the hell are you doing
I'm dancing you're dancing who are you
dancing with I'll give you a hint
starts with a C and it ends with you and
me getting married okay even in virtual
reality I wouldn't dance with you Keith
okay you'd be surprised what you're up
for in here hey Keith Keith okay that's
enough
all right folks virtual reality is a
powerful technology it should be used
responsibly make stop making out with me
in virtual reality he's started
we got security in here security get him
out of here I'm really sorry
everyone we obviously picked the wrong
guy to try the new
[Applause]
who's the boss now O'Brien alright
that's great
yeah which way am I facing alright
you